Шановні восьмикласники,
на цьому уроці географії ви будете
працювати з Галиною Іванівною Карпюк.
Шановні восьмикласники,
у 6 та 7 класі ви вивчали
природні зони світу і кожного материка.
Перед вами на карті природні
зональні комплекси позначено кольорами
і місце України, ось я показую,
місце України відображає поширення
в Україні трьох природних зон,
ми бачимо 3 відтінки кольорів.
Отже, Україна з її великою територією
також підлягає закону
широтної зональності.
На території України
сформувалася зона мішаних лісів,
зона широколистих лісів,
лісостепова і степова.
Ці зони сформувалися на
рівнинній частині території України,
оскільки вона розміщена, наша країна,
у межах Східноєвропейської рівнини.
Зони змінюються з півночі на південь,
але чіткого простягання в широтному
напрямку ми не спостерігаємо,
оскільки крім сонячної радіації -
основного кліматичного чинника,
на формування природних
зон впливають й інші чинники,
з якими ми познайомимося упродовж уроку.
Тема уроку: мішані ліси
і широколисті ліси.
Зона мішаних лісів охоплює
північну частину території України.
Вона простягається від західного кордону
з Польщею до східного кордону з Росією
і лежить між північним кордоном
України та умовною лінією,
яка проходить приблизно по обласних
центрах: Луцьк, Рівне, Житомир, Київ.
І далі південніше Чернігова через
Ніжин і північніше Сум через Глухів.
Ця територія
охоплює приблизно четверту
частину території України.
Зона широколистих лісів поширюється
на південь від зони мішаних лісів
і сягає південного кордону
в цій місцевості
території України і з
Румунією, і Молдовою.
Зона широколистих лісів немає широтного
простягання як зона мішаних лісів.
А знаходиться у вигляді такого
великого масиву в західній частині України
від Передкарпаття до приблизно межі
Хмельницької, Тернопільської областей.
Що потрібно знати для
характеристики природної зони?
Передусім пригадати план.
Будь-яка природна зона
характеризується в чіткій послідовності:
географічне положення, рельєф, клімат,
внутрішні води, ґрунти, рослинний
світ, тваринний світ і охорона природи.
Чому саме така послідовність?
Тому що це дає можливість
нам розуміти особливості
формування тих чи інших компонентів
природи у межах цього природного комплексу
і пригадати всі взаємозв'язки, які ви
вивчали в попередніх курсах географії.
З чого починаємо?
Як правило, починаємо
з тектонічної будови.
Тектонічна будова - це та основа, той
фундамент, на якому формуються ландшафти.
На тектонічній карті ми зараз окреслимо
зону мішаних лісів і побачимо, що
це дуже неоднорідна територія, незважаючи
на те, що це Східноєвропейська платформа
її південно-західна окраїна.
Ми бачимо, що основну частину
тут займає Український щит.
Це темно червоні і рожеві кольори.
Український щит - це ділянка, яка має,
як правило, висхідні
повільні вертикальні рухи.
А ось світло-рожевий колір -
це окраїни або крила щита.
Таким чином, майже половину
території займає Український щит.
На схід від нього заходить
Дніпровсько-Донецька западина,
а на захід - Волино-Подільська плита.
Дніпровсько-Донецька
западина - це прогин між
Українським щитом і
Воронезьким кристалічним масивом,
відроги якого заходять в
цю зону на північному сході.
Розуміючи як вибудувана в тектонічному
відношенні територія мішаних лісів,
ми можемо з вами
розглянути і геологічну будову.
Але передусім давайте коротенько зробимо
маленький екскурс в геологічне минуле.
В Палеозої ця територія мала
неоднорідну тектонічну будову.
Вся західна частина або, як ми
можемо тепер сказати, Правобережна -
це процеси горотворення,
а на сході ми маємо морський басейн.
В середині Мезозою, крейдовий
період, вся територія покривалась морями.
В палеогеновий період, в Кайнозої,
ми маємо в основному
морські басейни, мілководні,
але уже з’являється ділянка суші в
межах теперішнього Українського щита.
Весь неогеновий період - це підняття,
регресія моря і ми маємо суходіл.
І ось потрібно ще нагадати, коли
ви вивчали палеогеографічні умови,
як заходи в межах України - язик
льодовика, давнього льодовика,
дві епохи зледеніння, пригадуєте, одна з
них мала поширення на північному заході
і великим ось таким масивом
спускалася на південь по долині Дніпра.
Це мало значний вплив на природу
сучасної природної зони мішаних лісів.
І ось тепер ми можемо відкрити
і зрозуміти геологічну карту.
Перед вами геологічна карта.
Уявимо, що верхні кілька метрів
чи кілька десятків метрів зняли.
І тепер перед нами кольорами
відображений вік гірських порід,
які залягають під
четвертинними відкладними або
відкладками антропогенного періоду.
Червоний колір - це найдавніші
породи - архейська ера.
Архейська і протерозойська ера.
Зелений колір - це
породи мезозойської ери,
а світло-коричневий і жовтий
кольори на карті - це гірські породи,
які утворилися в кайнозойську еру.
Що ми бачимо на геологічній карті?
У межах Українського щита ми бачимо
поширення порід Архею і Протерозою.
Що це за породи?
Це породи, вік яких
понад 2 мільярди років.
Тверді кристалічні породи
магматично-метаморфічного походження,
які сьогодні ви бачите навколо себе.
Це граніти, базальти,
гнейси, габро та інші,
а по розломах утворенні руди.
На поверхні щита породи
виходять дуже великим масивом,
особливо в долинах річок.
На захід поширені породи мезозойської ери,
причому ми зняли тільки
пласт антропогенних відкладів,
а вже бачимо, що немає ні
палеогенових, ні неогенових відкладів,
тобто зразу відкривається
гірські породи крейдового періоду.
Це світ льодовика.
Він зніс всі ці породи південніше,
а на поверхню вийшли
досить давні гірські породи,
які ми можемо сьогодні називати з вами
повсякденні:
крейда, вапняк, пісковик.
Так само ці гірські породи
виходять на поверхню
на схилах Воронезького
кристалічного масиву.
Ці гірські породи є також
цінними в нашому господарстві.
А ось по долині Дніпра в межах цієї зони
поширені переважно гірські
породи Палеогену, Неогену,
тобто кайнозойської ери,
переважно піски і глини.
У межах широколистих лісів поширення
порід кайнозойської ери повсюдно,
тільки частково по глибоких
долинах Дністра і його приток
ми можемо побачити відслонення
гірських порід палеозойської ери,
що, насправді, є дуже
рідкісним явищем для України.
Давайте тепер спробуємо уявити,
як ми можемо оцінити таку ситуацію:
Український щит, Волино-Подільська
плита, Дніпровсько-Донецька западина
і гірські породи різного віку.
Звичайно, передусім це
будуть будівельні матеріали.
Отже,
зона мішаних лісів не буде
мати тільки природні ландшафти,
вже хоча б тому що поширені кар'єри з
видобування гранітів, гнейсів, базальтів
і ви їх навколо сьогодні
бачите у вигляді щебню, збудованих доріг,
будівель із залізобетону.
Ось отакі кар'єри як на
правому нижньому малюнку -
це дуже поширене явище
для північної частини України,
де розробляться такі гірські породи.
Окрім гранітів, гнейсів,
тобто будівельного каміння,
розробляються інші гірські породи.
Передусім там, де поширені породи Мезозою,
ми бачимо кар'єри, в яких
видобувають вапняки, крейду, мергель.
Ми бачимо кар'єри, де розробляють
титанові руди на Українському щиті.
Ось отакий вигляд
мають сьогодні місцевості,
де добувають бурштин на півночі України.
Схоже дуже на місячний ландшафт.
Такий вигляд мають місцевості,
де починають розробляти торф,
тобто розроблення мінеральних ресурсів
зони мішаних лісів - це одна з причин,
яка зменшує площу
природних ландшафтів у цій зоні.
Як впливає тектоніка на рельєф?
Ви вже пам'ятаєте, що рельєф -
це передусім фізична карта,
на якій зеленим кольором
позначені низовини,
а жовтим кольором – височини.
Інших форм рельєфу на
східноєвропейській рівнині в межах
українського Полісся, як правило, немає.
Отже, по домінування кольорів, ми бачимо,
переважають низовини, тобто зелений колір.
Перш за все - це Поліська низовина,
яка простягається і по
Правобережжю і по Лівобережжю.
Там де Український щит
займає територію Житомирської,
частково Рівненської області,
ми бачимо
жовтий колір - це височина,
Придніпровська височина, яка
заходить в зону мішаних лісів України.
І на Сумщині це відроги
Середньо-Російської височини,
які відповідають на сьогодні
Воронезькому кристалічному масиву.
Отже,
рельєф України ми вивчаємо
після тектонічної будови
і ми розуміємо поширені в межах
цієї зони низовини ділянок і височини.
Височини пов'язані з Українським щитом,
а низовини пов'язані із
западинами і плитами.
Як оцінити рельєф?
Рельєф низовинний переважно і височинний.
А, отже, він сприятливий для
заселення людством цієї території,
для будівництва доріг,
промислових об'єктів,
для розташування тут населених пунктів,
для обробітку полів, для
ведення лісозаготівельних робіт.
Тобто рельєф, привабливий для
людини і господарської діяльності.
Він сприятливий для
освоєння цієї території.
З наукової точки зору ми
можемо сформулювати так:
геоморфологічні умови українського Полісся
сприятливі для проживання
людини і господарської діяльності,
я б додала слово – «відносно» сприятливі.
Чому?
Тому що низовини, особливо якщо вони
майже плоскі і мають незначний похил,
як правило, заболочуються, якщо
для цього сприятливі кліматичні умови.
Спробуємо подивитися
які це кліматичні умови.
Перегорніть карту атласу і
відкрийте кліматичну карту,
яку ви вивчали на уроках «Клімат України».
Ця карта
відображає
розподіл температури і опадів,
а також позначені переважаючі вітри.
Що ми бачимо на карті?
Українське Полісся і
зона широколистяних лісів
має помірний клімат,
але ізотерми показують певні відмінності.
Ось ми маємо ізотерму 18
градусів липня місяця найтеплішого
і ось ми маємо 19 градусів.
Тобто, літо майже однакове:
18-19 градусів.
Ближче до Прикарпаття
температури трошки знижуються,
а на півдні, в зоні широколистих лісів,
температури від +19 до +20 градусів.
Це тому, що влітку основну
кількість сонячного тепла
ця територія
отримує від сонця.
Карта, якщо ви глянете в свій атлас,
яка показує нам
кількість сонячної радіації,
показує що ця кількість майже однакова,
але ось ця північно-західна частинка
отримує трошки менше
ніж північно-східна і середня.
Чому?
Справа в тім, що
кут падіння сонячних променів однаковий,
але ця територія має більш хмарну погоду
і кількість розсіяної радіація зростає.
Отже,
з заходу на схід більше тепла, тому
що тут менша хмарність
на сході, а на заході – більша.
Якщо ми подивимося
розподіл температур взимку,
а ми маємо на це зважити, тому що
це дуже впливатиме на формування
рослинності в цій зоні,
то на заході ми маємо всього -4.
Середня температура визначена
упродовж багаторічних спостережень,
не будемо зважати на
особливості зими 2020 року.
А ось далі йде
-5, -6, -7, -8.
Чому?
Тому що кут падіння сонячних
променів взимку дуже невеликий,
а тепло надходить переважно
циклонами з Атлантики.
Атлантичний океан не замерзає взимку,
за будь-якої зими не замерзає.
І тому циклон, який
формується над його акваторією
приносить на нашу територію тепло
і чим далі від Атлантики,
тим холодніша зима.
Для рослинності важливо -4 чи -8.
Кількість опадів найбільша, порівняно з
іншими регіонами України - 600-700 мм.
Для тих, хто хоче глибше
зрозуміти особливості, подивіться.
Ось є такі невеличкі ділянки,
де кількість опадів чомусь більша.
Давайте згадаємо третій
чинник, крім сонячної радіації
і циркуляція атмосфери,
підстильна поверхня
Це починається Придніпровська
височина і Словечансько-Овруцький кряж,
а це вже починаються відроги
Середньо-Російської височини
і повітряні маси, які
доходять до цієї місцевості,
поступово втрачають вологу,
піднімаючись по їх схилах.
Адже ми знаємо, з підняттям
вверх температура знижується
і конденсується волога,
яка є в повітряній масі.
Таким чином ми з вами бачимо, що
кліматичні умови дещо відрізняються
навіть в межах зони мішаних лісів.
В зоні широколистих лісів
кількість опадів приблизно така ж,
але кількість сонячного тепла дещо більша.
Температура зростає, а раз піднімається
температура, збільшується випаровування.
Отже, в таких кліматичних умовах
ми можемо мати з вами,
давайте оцінимо з точки зору
господарства і проживання людини,
комфортні умови для проживання людини,
і можливість вирощувати майже всі
сільськогосподарські культури
помірного поясу.
Причому,
що в зоні мішаних лісів,
що зовні широколистих лісів
всі ці культури можна вирощувати.
Особливо за сучасного рівня
розвитку генетики й селекції,
коли виведені і більш посухостійкі,
і більш холодостійкі культури.
Практично,
ми можемо вирощувати всі культури
в межах і однієї зони, і іншої.
Тут вже стане питання доцільності,
економічної доцільності.
Але зволоження буде відрізнятися.
Якщо на півночі при таких температурах
- це буде надмірне зволоження,
тобто опадів більше, ніж може їх
випаруватися ніж випаровується,
то в зоні широколистих лісів
коефіцієнт зволоження тільки в
незначній мірі перевищує одиничку.
Тобто зволоження достатнє
і тільки місцями може бути
надмірним, ближче до Передкарпаття.
Тепер спробуємо
оцінити ці умови кліматичні
з точки зору агрокліматичного районування,
тобто якщо глянути на карту
агрокліматичного районування,
то, по суті,
майже вся територія і зони мішаних лісів,
і зони широколистих лісів,
і навіть частково лісостепу
попадає в одну агрокліматичну зону з
деякими відмінностями тільки у зволоженні.
Отже, кліматичні умови ми оцінили.
Слідом ми можемо охарактеризувати
і води поверхневі.
Поверхневі води - це річки, озера, болота.
А також глянем на підземні води.
Чому ми їх вивчаємо після
рельєфу і після клімату?
Тому що на характер річок, на
характер течії впливає рельєф,
а на режим річки – клімат.
І вивчати в іншому порядку – недоречно.
Тому перегортаємо сторіночку
поверхневі води
і нам карта показує -
все українське Полісся,
майже все, - це долина Дніпра
та його приток: лівої - Десни і
правої - Прип'яті.
На крайньому заході,
вздовж кордону з Польщею,
в нас є річка Західний Буг, вона
не відноситься до басейну Дніпра.
Це річка вже басейну Вісли.
На заході України
поєднуються, дивіться, ми бачимо
вододіли кількох річкових басейнів -
вододіл Дніпра і Південного
Бугу, ось тут проходить,
а оце басейн Дністра і вододіл
Дністра із Західним Бугом.
Таким чином ми маємо
кілька річкових басейнів,
але охарактеризувати велику
кількість річок дуже коротко можна.
Яким чином?
Подивіться.
Всі річки українського Полісся, які
протікають переважно по низовинах,
широкі, тихоплинні, з низькими
берегами й широкими заплавами.
А річки, які перетинають
Подільську височину і Придніпровську
будуть мати глибшу річкову
долину, крутіші береги.
Для режиму характерно, як правило, -
нестійкий зимовий льодостав.
От цього року його не було.
Весняна повінь може бути кілька
днів, може бути навіть кілька тижнів.
І чим далі на північ,
тим повінь триваліша.
Що таке річки Полісся?
Оскільки Полісся - найбільш
забезпечений водою регіон,
то ми маємо можливості і на перспективу
розміщувати там водомісткі виробництва,
адже - це прісні води.
Ці води живлять міста,
їх використовують для побутових потреб,
ці води можуть використовуватися у
водомістких промислових виробництвах,
а також для виробництва електроенергії.
Але це можуть бути тільки
маленькі електростанції, розміщені,
як правило,
на невеликих річках, в межах Українського
щита або Подільської височини.
А тепер карта ґрунтів.
Ось ці хвойні ліси, які раніше
займали майже 90 відсотків території.
Чому ми так впевнено про це кажемо?
Тому що ці ґрунти могли сформуватися
тільки під хвойним лісом.
Це дерново-підзолисті ґрунти,
у яких зверху невеликий,
як правило, прошарок дерну,
потім небагато гумусу,
а далі, кольору попелу золи, -
горизонт вимивання,
де поживні речовини вимиті
на значно більшу глибину.
Чому?
Тому що це територія,
яка на сьогодні має, як правило,
надмірне зволоження
і ще й зверху - подушка хвої,
яка не дає волозі випаровуватися
і вона просочується в глибину.
Такі ґрунти мають мало гумусу,
вони кислуваті
саме тому, що там багато хвої, яка
перегниває, перепріває, дає цю кислоту.
І для того, щоб ці ґрунти використовувати
в господарстві, їх потрібно удобрювати,
місцями навіть виводити надміру вологу,
а також вапнувати, щоб
нейтралізувати зайву кислотність.
Дерново-підзолисті ґрунти
поширені по всій зоні мішаних лісів,
але ось ці фіолетові плямочки –
це лучні ґрунти, які утворилися в
долинах річок під високотравними луками.
На південь від зони мішаних лісів, в зоні
широколистих лісів, ґрунти змінюються.
Ви бачите, що цього підзолистого світло
горизонту не стає, це сірі лісові ґрунти.
Ясно-сірі, темно-сірі, які мають
значно вищий вміст гумусу,
меншу кислотністю і можуть
давати значно вищі врожаї.
Саме такі ґрунти і спричинили значне
освоєння зони широколистих лісів
і поширення, як правило,
сільськогосподарських ландшафтів.
Тобто полів, сінокосів і пасовищ.
Карта тваринного світу,
як правило, ніколи не показує межу між
мішаними лісами і широколистяними.
Тварини легше переміщуються
і майже однакові тварини і в цій
зоні, і в іншій.
Дещо більше вони
збереглися в зоні мішаних лісів,
тому що там більша частка
природних ландшафтів.
Сюди заходять зубри, тут живуть лосі,
олені, козулі, дикі кабани, лисиці, зайці,
світ птахів.
Щоб зберегти це розмаїття
тваринного і рослинного світу,
ці унікальні ландшафти лісів,
мішаних і широколистих,
створена мережа заповідників.
В зоні мішаних лісів – це, крім
Шацького національного парку,
Рівненський заповідник,
Поліський,
а також
в зоні
Чорнобильської атомної електростанції
зовсім недавно створений
новий заповідник біосферний,
який вражає нас успіхами природи
у протистоянні з людиною.
Сьогодні там велике розмаїття
тих тварин, які жили завжди –
це лосі, косулі, дикі
кабани, зайці, лисиці.
А також тих, які вже
давно не зустрічалися.
Тобто в цій зоні можна вже зустріти,
в межах заповідника, бурого ведмедя,
заходять зубри,
заселені, успішно прижилися й
адаптувалися коні Пржевальського.
Повсюдно буяє рослинність
і хочеться вітати таку
перемогу природи над людиною.
Хочеться згадати слова Ліни Костенко.
Увага на екран.
І тому, коли ви прийдете до
лісу, пам’ятайте ці кілька правил.
Дивимось на екран.
І будьте самі обережні.
В лісі, як правило, не видно горизонту.
Не заблукайте,
не попадіть на непрохідне болото.
Вчіться в місцевих жителів, місцевих
мешканців, як жити в злагоді з лісом
як бути багатим від лісу і
зберегти ліс наступним поколінням.
Домашнє завдання.
Передусім полистайте карти атласу.
Пригадайте все, що
ми з вами вчили на уроці.
Уважно роздивіться малюнки, які
є в підручнику, можете почитати параграф.
В кожному підручнику,
хто б не був його автором,
цей параграф називається однаково:
«Зона мішаних лісів, зона
широколистяних лісів».
Зробіть віртуальну подорож в
Чорнобильський заповідник.
Ви побачите прекрасні
матеріали, чудові фотографії.
Ви зустрінете прекрасні описи
наукових співробітників заповідника
і вам захочеться відвідати ці місця.
В зоні широколистих лісів
також багато заповідників,
але вони більш доступні
і на сьогодні ви відвідати можете
будь-який з національних парків,
проїхатись дорогами України.
Зупиніться,
зійдіть на обочину,
послухайте ліс.
Дякую за увагу.